this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armouries museum in the uk which houses
a collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history in this
episode jonathan is taking another look
at the world war ii era weaponry of
battlefield 5. that was the volks stern
governor people's assault rifle so you
would expect from that that it's an
automatic weapon in fact battlefield
models it as an automatic weapon it is
not
if you want to see our previous episode
on battlefield 5 make sure to check it
out we've got a handy link down in the
description of this video and make sure
to subscribe as well as we've got tons
of content just like this on the channel
including loadout a show where we take a
look at the history and impact of some
of the most iconic weapons in gaming
from the shotgun and m1 garand through
to the desert eagle and the minigun we
collaborated with jonathan on loadout 2
so he'll be making a fair few
appearances on that show as well but
without further ado let's see more of
jonathan's take on battlefield 5.
the well gun those of you who didn't
already know might have guessed the well
part of the name is from the same origin
as the well rod why well well well
well in garden city is where station
nine
of the special operations executive
was based and they were one of the
stations that came up with all sorts of
interesting bits of kit for james bond
types and so this is the well done gun
in this case meaning sub machine gun as
you all well aware by now so they came
up with something that was very short
you don't really get a sense of that in
the game because the stock is deployed
which it should be when fighting
if i can um deploy this one without
scratching the very nice blue finish on
this by the way we can see the stock
unfolds
latches into place there and the butt
plate folds down and locks into place so
it looks a bit crude almost like a sten
but it's a bit more sophisticated in
some ways we have this whacking great
open receiver which strikes me as a
tremendously bad idea you can see this
in the game we're not modeling
unreliability in the battlefield series
so not a problem in real life i think it
might be might be more of a problem i
don't know other than the short overall
length and the tactical flexibility of a
folding stock this doesn't really do
anything that a sten gun doesn't do
you'd think if you were going to design
your own gucci submachine gun for sneaky
beaky operations you would get rid of
the weak point of the sten gun the
magazine became the weak point of the
sten gun and it's apart from anything
else it's dual columns of ammunition but
feeding from one column they get
smooshed together into one column for
feeding which is not ideal it's a bit
like being on the road and two lanes of
traffic merge and if people are nice to
each other and let each other in like a
zipper it's all goes well but of course
human beings aren't like that and
neither another is ammunition so you get
stoppages that's the well gun it's a
really nice important bit of firearms
history and it's a it's quite a nice
mixture actually of crude bits of weld
that have been ground off and quite a
nice bit of um
blue finish and quite a cool almost
sci-fi
diesel punk look to it
this is another intriguing and very
british second world war gun because go
not because go geo standing for gas
operated it's unusual for a for a
firearm to denote how it's operated in
its name but in this case it's because
the standard vickers gun was recoil
operated from the beginning the vicar's
maxim gun so it was a handy way in it
within the naming system to denote a
different type of vicar's gun it's
completely different in fact so the the
number one had a spade grip at the rear
and was for mounting on vehicles and is
sort of somewhat famous for being
preferred by
the original sas special air service in
the desert and they they liked this
relatively compact i suppose high rate
of fire machine gun which was really
designed as an anti-aircraft or mounted
gun the difference as you see in the
game and as you've seen the one behind
me although the example i've got here is
missing the bipod um is that they
redesigned it so the other mark was the
ground
service version so it's got a pistol
grip
and a more conventional butt stock so
you can actually get in and shoulder it
and a wooden foregrip to actually
run around firing it from the hip which
is very sort of comic book and slash
video game slash movie but that's the
kind of people these guys were ideally
they'd be sneaking about not engaging
the enemy at all but if they had to much
like some modern special operations
forces high volume of firepower to sort
of break contact and get the hell away
was found to be useful part of that is
having a substantial drum magazine on
the top of the gun to be able to feed
the sort of the voracious appetites as
it were of 900-ish rounds per minute
which i think is about that right in the
game so the drum on this thing is 100
friends which is really the minimum you
need for a machine gun without rate of
fire
what we've just seen there is
one of several attempts to turn the well
in this case the short magazinely
enfield version of that bolt action
rifle into a
fully automatic gun a machine gun of
those um three designs i'm aware of only
one of them was used in so it was
designed for use in the first world war
the the others the charlton and this the
turner were produced as
expedient designs so a way to turn
something common and cheap lee enfield
rifles into something more capable as a
support weapon so in this case the the
turner turner refers to
russell a russell j turner who was an
american and this was for the canadian
forces and so by
bolting a gas
tube and piston to the to the side of
your or otherwise integrating it into
your limb field you could turn a turn
bolt weapon
into
a fully automatic one and from
everything i've read and seen the both
versions were relatively slow rates of
fire and i suspect they've got it pretty
right
in the game there and they have the
along with the howl as well they have
very much uh almost a steampunk look to
them because they look like an edwardian
rifle with all sorts of tubes and
housings grafted to it because that's
what they are so firing the same
cartridge as the both the enfield and
the brand but doing it in a sort of
heath robinson rube goldberg way with
gubbins attached um to the rifle i think
the key difference with the turner which
i'm not sure is really evident from from
playing the game necessarily
is that it wasn't so much just stuff
grafted onto the side like the others it
was
you take the barrel you keep the
furniture that wouldn't stop
and then you throw out pretty much
everything else i don't know it's like
keeping keeping the spoiler on your on
your uh ford escort and and replacing
the actual car with a mustang
you're you're uh still gonna cut it's
still gonna cost you quite a lot of
money to convert your enfields
this is a one of the occasions where i
i'm forced to grab the next nearest
thing that we have in the
museum collection to what we're seeing
and that's because the m1917 um
so-called trench carbine was
approached tonight there will be a
handful in the world
what i'm holding here is one of the
original run of c96 carbines um the
m1917 differs in quite a few details
from this but it's not really that
different they are semi-automatic which
i think is what we're seeing in the game
i don't remember
i haven't seen this thing firing
automatic i think you'd know it if it
was because the very small lightweight
bolt in the broom handle with the
schnell foil variants that are automatic
this thing absolutely rips um at about a
thousand plus rounds per minute this
thing doesn't this is semi-automatic so
the 19 the main difference is the lack
of a detachable 20 round magazine now
what we
see happen
in cycling animation
is just the bolt moving i think i'm
right in saying as you can hopefully see
from me compressing the barrel
on this carbine that's not actually how
c9 works yes the bolt does come back but
much like a slide operated pistol it's
short recoil so it has to
start
moving with the whole barrel assembly so
effectively the slide and the barrel
move together as they do in a slide
operated pistol this does it
with a bolt with an internal bolt so yes
the bolt moves but the two are locked
together for that much travel
it's not much and it's so little that i
might even be missing it in the game i
mainly don't think so because the way
they've attached the imaginary scope to
this model it appears it's attached to
the barrel which is a bad thing you
don't want extra weight slowing down the
reciprocation of your barrel assembly
admittedly this already has that in the
longer barrel they will affect that into
the
geometry of the working parts if you
then
weld on a scope mount in the scope the
quite scopes are heavy you're made out
of steel and glass typically that's
liable to impact
functioning negatively it's going to
impact accuracy because the site is on a
moving part of the gun that's never good
i don't know if it's me but the
danish craig jorgensen design used by
norway as well as denmark but it seems
like the crag is getting more popular in
video gaming in the last sort of five
years or something i don't remember it
being in anything and then suddenly i'm
seeing it in several
several games we featured it on this
show before pro famous if it's famous at
all for uh its unusual loading system
with the hopper pseudo hopper on the
side so in the original design you swung
it open from the rear forwards and then
you you put your rounds in one of the
time into an internal magazine from the
side which is
pretty unconventional can't think of
another design that does it in the same
way it's noteworthy for that i don't it
wasn't
a particular advantage i don't think it
was a particular disadvantage either so
the crack was moderately successful in
in the grand scheme of service rifles
the norwegian version
which is what the american version was
based on
changed it so that the hopper hinged
open at the side
in both cases when you when you hinge it
open it takes spring tension off the
rounds so instead of a
follower with a spring pushing up from
directly below it's pushing up from
pushing in and up from the side so by
opening that up you relieve all the
spring tension which means to unload you
literally just tip out all your rounds
and only be the one in the chamber if
you chambered around that you'd have to
unload with the bolt in gaming terms
that gives us something visually
different to to play with i don't know
if it
might give you any sort of reloading
advantage in terms of animation speed it
doesn't look like it it doesn't go for
the sort of dump in all five rounds at
once slam it shut because after all this
is meant to be a
slow operating rifle because it's a
primarily a sniping type rifle in the
game speaking of which i have not seen
i've limited experience with the crag
admittedly but i've not seen scoped
versions of the crag other than
sporting target shooting hunting rifles
that have been made from crags because
you can drill and tap and mount scopes
to anything there's no reason why would
it be impediment and actually the crag
is a good choice for scoping in theory
because of the side mounted magazine
that was the volkswave people's assault
rifle so you would expect from that that
it's an automatic weapon in fact
battlefield models it as an automatic
weapon it is not here is a real one and
it has a switch but all the switch does
is go from fire
foyer
you safe safe disengages the trigger
entirely it has quite the recoil spring
because it is straight blowback there's
nothing delaying or locking this shut
this just does it by the sheer weight of
the bolts which in this case includes
the whole barrel casing so that's that's
it cocked
it's on fire
gun goes bang
gun cycles itself
because it's got ammunition in it in
real life um release the trigger to the
reset
and you fire it again it is a
semi-automatic weapon there is no way to
make this for auto without filing some
parts and changing some parts and
converting it to full auto so despite
the name it was not intended to be fully
automatic but it does
embody the other aspects of the assault
rifle it's compact
not hugely light but lightness was not a
huge worry as long as it wasn't heavier
than a service rifle that was sort of
good enough in those days
and it fires that intermediate cartridge
which is easier to control in rapid fire
something that is
relatively easy to use but is capable of
a high volume of fire does make sense
this is another of these last ditch
weapons uh very important piece of
history for for firearms anyway if
you're making weapons like this there's
a good chance you're going to lose the
war so this is um in some ways superior
to the stand but a little bit ambitious
and a bit too too little too late really
thanks as ever for watching guys we've
got links in the description if you'd
like to donate to the museum to the
royal armouries but in any case thanks
very much
[Music]
you